this month the spectator becomes the
first magazine in history to print
10,000 issues and we'd like to celebrate
with you subscribe to The Spectator for
12 weeks for just 12 pounds plus we'll
send you a bottle of commemorative
spectator gin absolutely free go to
spectator code at UK forward slash
celebrate
hello and welcome to this episode of
audio reads it's the spectators 10,000th
Edition and historian Tom Holland writes
about the magazine's winning recipe in
this week's issue here he is The
Spectator is a child of the 19th century
and damned proud of it
first published in 1828 the link
provided by its 10,000 issues to a
long-vanished age of Regency waste lines
and Romantic poets is one of the great
wonders of journalism its success was
built upon Victorian foundations yet it
is a peculiarity of the current media
landscape that The Spectator the only
current affairs magazine actually to
have been published in the 19th century
should in many ways seemed the least
Victorian of the lot the New Statesman
prospect standpoint all have a certain
quality of moral earnestness that one
could imagine Gladstone admiring The
Spectator by contrast seems to breathe
the coffee perfumed air of an earlier
age right from its first edition it has
been shaded by the specter of a vanished
sensibility in its morals its values its
style there is little of the wing collar
about it dress the spectator up in
period costume and it would have to
sport a powdered wig the magazine has
always cast the certain wistful gaze
back at the 18th century this is evident
enough from its title to launch a new
publication back in 1828 was no less a
leap of faith than it would be today but
to call it The Spectator was a gesture
of self-confidence so lavish that it
might have seemed to verge on the
conceited the original spectator founded
in 1711 was a daily publication which
despite folding after a year had come to
be enshrined over the course of the 18th
century as a supreme model of English
prose as David Butterfield describes in
his history of the magazine Joseph
Anderson and Richard Steele the men who
had written the essays which constituted
the spectators daily offering were
admired by even the most
acting critics who ever wished to attain
an english-style familiar but not coarse
and elegant but not ostentatious must
give his days and nights to the study of
addison this decree coming from the
robustly Tory dr. Johnson was praised
indeed for a man who had ranked as a
most notorious Whig to call a magazine
The Spectator then was to follow in the
footsteps of giants but robert rental
the enterprising scottish radical who
served as its first editor knew what he
was doing Addison and Steele had given
to mr. Spectator the attributes of a man
I dearly qualified to provide a newly
urban and commercial society with its
role model interested in the affairs of
the day knowledgeable about literature
art and music sociable amusing and
amused above all mr. Spectator affected
to eschew the rancorous polarization
that then as now was such a
characteristic of English society both
Addison and Steele knew that the
medicine of their wigger II was likely
to be swallowed by their readers if
sugared with wit it was a measure of
their success that James Boswell who
defined himself throughout his great
biography of dr. Johnson as being like
his hero a Tory should consciously have
sought to emulate to the easy
disposition of mr. Spectator indeed
Boswell wrote I hadn't custom myself so
much to laugh at everything that it
required time to render my imagination
solid for rental as it had been for
Addison and Steele the great enemy of
journalism was dullness today's
spectator almost two hundred years on
still manifestly subscribed to that
conviction it is evident in its
patronage of writers who have variously
drunk themselves to death
or gone to prison for possession of
cocaine in the surge of sex scandals
that during the Edit editorship of the
current prime minister added so hugely
to the gaiety of the nation in its
willingness to probe the limits of what
liberal up in
in Britain today regards as acceptable
and to do so in a tone of satire that
Swift might well have enjoyed it is
evident to in its ongoing commitment to
the discovery made long ago by Addison
and Steele that a political perspective
can most effectively be promoted by
sweetening it with variety and lightness
of style much as Pope in the original
version of the gun C ad shuddered before
the prospect that wits vane works shall
fall and universal dullness cover all so
does the spectator today small wonder
then that its blog should be called
coffeehouse by the reign of Queen Anne
who statue like a Tudor Reed deity
stands just around the corner from the
spectators office the coffeehouse had
come to be dreaded by its enemies as a
center of the most seditious indecent
and scandalous discourses and by its
defenders as a shrine to polite
conversation two Boswell who reveled in
the opportunities it provided to
eavesdrop on conversation and to observe
the ways of the world it constituted a
veritable monument to the ideals of
Addison and Steele there was nowhere
better he mused for a person of
imagination and feeling such as The
Spectator finally describes sometimes
refined sometimes rambunctious sometimes
learn it sometimes lush sometimes formal
sometimes frivolous the coffeehouse
constituted a shrine to the spirit of
journalism no bad role model then for a
magazine to have even one that can boast
of having chalked up 10,000 editions and
of ranking as the longest-lived current
affairs magazine there has ever been
that was Tom Holland and now Douglas
Murray I love my fellow hacks even when
I disagree with them by Douglas Murray
it's one way to keep in touch with
people each morning somewhere between
the first coffee of the day and the
first drink I open my computer log on to
social media
see which of my friends or colleagues is
trending today oh I think as I see their
names flesh up
I wonder what Julie charles allison
james rod usually rod has done now then
i click and read all about their crimes
usually through a filter of people
laboring under the impression that a
writer's job is to say what everyone
else has already agreed on the howls
incidentally mostly emanating from
people who in no sense subscribed to the
organ in which the crime is said to have
occurred this is one of the brightest
moments of my day for at these times i
feel a huge surge of communal pride i do
not know if it is the same in all
professions I don't know if Chartered
Accountants love other Chartered
Accountants taxi drivers love other taxi
drivers or actors love anyone other than
themselves but I do love hacks journals
and opinion mongers whether their views
are in alignment with my own matters
less and less with the years the fact is
that the more I see them attacked the
more grateful I am for this strange
disputatious disagreeable tribe take
Peter Hitchens I have no idea whether
Peter is right or wrong in his claim
that this country has done the wrong
thing in locking itself down to avoid
coronavirus but every time I see him
sally forth in print or on screen to
argue his case i thank god for whatever
it was in hitchens milk that produced
such argumentative unintimidating suns
just as the desire to speak up
transcends political tribes so the
temptation to shut things down is not
confined to any one political side
recently I wrote something nice about
the Guardian contributor Susanne Moore
who had done an exceptional thing by
publishing something in the Guardian
despite its being true yet after my more
encomium
a number of otherwise contented readers
got in touch to remonstrate how could I
say anything nice about Miss Moore they
asked had I not seen what she once said
about the male sex the royal family or
any number of other things and my answer
is the same I don't agree with anyone on
everything but as I grow older I am glad
her and gladder for people who keep
firing off in style
whatever the incoming flag it was
William Nicholson in his film about CS
Lewis Shadowlands who came up with that
beautiful line we read to know we are
not alone a feeling that approximates to
the sensation Aristotle called
anagnorisis the moment of discovery or
recognition great art regularly hits us
with this emotion the discovery that
someone else lived who felt as we have
felt well I would propose that a less
grandiose often coarser but equally
significant quality marks out desirable
magazine writing as online readers will
know in recent weeks I have been
rereading some of my favorite spectator
column lists of recent decades and one
thing this is clarified is the fact that
for me the definition of good writing
includes something which makes me
whistle and think I am so glad that
someone has said that out loud sometimes
it is on a deep moral issue like Mary
Wakefield writing on abortion sometimes
it is a matter of artistic judgment as
Lloyd Evans managed in a theater column
in 2015 when he summed up in just four
paragraphs everything that is wrong with
George Bernard Shaw often it is
something so embarrassing that you just
punch the air with joy that somebody has
been willing to write and publish it
such as Cosmo Landers woman writing
about whether right-wing women are
better in bed
left-wing women yes or rod writing about
his and his wife's calamitous evening of
wine criticism if there isn't all that
much solidarity then perhaps it is in
part because we don't get together often
enough for the camaraderie to break out
in public some people would say that is
a good thing and that such disputatious
people ought to be kept apart the
spectators annual summer party provides
some evidence for this line of reasoning
it always starts off respectably enough
with politicians journalists and even
some television presenters networking
away happily but the best part is when
the Grandy's have cleared off when the
lasts pad or PR man has been led out by
the hand like a defeated chimpanzee then
you'll see the opinionated classes still
arguing it out with nothing to stop them
but last orders or oblivion whichever
comes first last year as the crowd
thinned I watched one hack finally
collapse backwards into a hedge at the
bottom of the garden without even the
hint of a crumpled ramrod straight they
stayed even as the ground came rushing
towards them I think most people were
too busy arguing to notice but someone
else got there first
and a cry went up that temporarily
stilled the discussion is there a doctor
in the garden during a short pause it
became clear that there was then the
voice again
is there a sober doctor in the garden a
couple of years back the editor had the
fine idea of throwing a hax only party
so we didn't all have to be on such good
behavior I think Nick Cohen was still
drinking then somehow I recall Jeremy
Clark being carried out more than once
the last time under someone's arms like
a rolled-up carpet a left-wing feminist
definitely me to do me it was a glorious
terrible messy disputatious hilarious
battlefield
of an evening we lost some of our best
men last night I said quietly to the
deputy editor the next day but I feel
like we made some small advances on the
enemy's territory
what are those enemies boredom
predictability obvious humorless Ness
dullness staleness the demand for boring
consensus of any kind most of all that
gang of people who seem to grow in
volume if not in number by the year who
cry you can't say that well bugger them
here's to the awkward squad where ever
they fall that was Douglas Murray and
now Mary Wakefield on coronavirus
uncertainty I had thought that actually
getting the coronavirus would bring
clarity then there would be some
satisfaction in meeting the enemy
feeling its spectral hands around my
lungs no such luck uncertainty is the
hallmark of the coronavirus even its
origins are murky wet markets or the
wooh hands center for disease control
who knows and who would ever believe the
Chinese government now anyway when
you've got it the sense of medieval
unknowing only deepens is this
definitely it will it get worse will it
come back my version of the virus began
with a nasty headache and a grubby
feeling of unease after which I threw up
on the bathroom floor that's disgusting
ma said my four-year-old son and Amir
towel with the look of patronizing
distaste I've never known a bug treat
its victim so differently my friends
have reported stabbing sore throats a
loss of taste and smell and numbness in
their fingertips a university in Wuhan
has just updated its list of official
first symptoms which now includes
headache dizziness muscle inflammation
fever diarrhea vomiting and coughing one
slight bit sad effect of this great
variation in symptoms is that it makes
phoning friends to share corona stories
peculiar
satisfying weren't the muscle aches
awful oh you didn't get them no no Saul
fruit for me
oh well that evening as I lay on the
sofa a happy thought occurred to me if
this was the virus then my husband he
works 16-hour days as a rule would have
to come home
I let myself imagine a fortnight in bed
with mild symptoms chatting to doorman
son through an open door more for me my
husband did rush home to look after me
he's an extremely kind man whatever
people assumed to the country but 24
hours later he said I feel weird and
collapsed I felt breathless sometimes
achy but Dom couldn't get out of bed day
in day out for 10 days he laid Dugger
with a high fever and spasms that made
the muscles lump and twitch in his legs
he could breathe but only in a limited
shallow way after a week we reached peak
Corona uncertainty day 6 as a turning
point I was told that's when you either
get better or head for ICU but was done
fighting off the bug or was he heading
for a ventilator who knew I sat on his
bed staring at his chest trying to count
his breaths per minute the little oxygen
reader we'd bought on Amazon indicated
he should be in hospital but his lips
weren't blue and he could talk in full
sentences such as please stop staring at
my chest sweetheart when do you go to
hospital do you really wait till the
lips go blue my son in his doctors
uniform administered Ribena with the
grim insistence of a Broadmoor nurse and
this might be my only really useful
advice for other corona parents or
single mothers with preschoolers get out
the doctor's kit make it your child's
job to take your temperature any game
that involves lying down as a good game
my other tip is to order at least a
liter of glue as Dom lays sweating my
son and I made a palace out of
polystyrene packaging I've lost in the
past that men who obsess over model
railways I won't laugh again
in a chaotic and unpredictable
environment there's nothing more
comforting than having total control
over your own tiny world long after my
son lost interest I was busy gluing on
towers and cutting coloured acetate to
make window panes
when Dom finally did make it up and into
the kitchen he found me applying cheap
plastic stickin gems to a loo roll tower
mum's busy playing I heard my son tell
Dom as he trotted off to fetch the
oxygen meter just a storm was beginning
to feel better it was reported that
Boris was heading in the other direction
into hospital I've been a slack
Christian during this era of biblical
plague churches are shut even Catholic
churches and somehow that makes more of
a difference than I thought it would one
of the reasons I converted was because
the doors of Catholic churches always
open the sanctuary lamp-lit and now
they're closed it feels as if someone's
turned off the spiritual stopcock but
what is there to do for the sick now
except pray
I left my polystyrene palace and got to
my knees for Boris and found to my
surprise that my prayers flowed easily
as if carried along in a current of
others after the uncertainty of the bug
itself we emerge from quarantine into
the almost comical uncertainty of London
lockdown everything and it's opposite
seems true people are frightened and
they're calm it's spring and it's not
queueing the pain and the most fun
you'll have all day there's been much
talk of the spirit of the Blitz but
there's something of the spirit of East
Berlin here in London to social
distancing is supposed to be a helpful
and communal act but people smile
noticeably less there's a woman job
where I've seen a few times now who runs
around scowling with an arm held out
horizontally to keep everyone at bay if
I didn't have a child in tow I'd be
tempted to walk straight into her but
then there are the birds which are
opiate now there's less noise to compete
with and the strange and wonderful
feeling of returning to a world in which
waiting is a thing it's like the 1990s
all over again people leaning on balls
staring into the distance scuffing their
trainers for something to do in the
queue and when you do meet a friend by
chance on the street and stop for a
guilty distance chat it feels utterly
joyful that was Mary Wakefield and last
tiny goat on what it's like to be the
spectators restaurant critic a fictional
spectator restaurant critic called
Forbes McAllister appeared on knowing me
knowing you with Alan Partridge
he was played by Patrick Marber and was
obviously based on Keith Waterhouse
bowtie mad eyes even if Waterhouse was
never the restaurant critic at this
magazine McAllister was on TV to show
off Lord Byron's dueling pistols and a
lock of his stupid hair he bought them
to annoy Michael Winner
then restaurant critic of The Sunday
Times are you entirely motivated by
hatred Partridge asked McAllister it was
his best ever question yes I think I am
said McAllister rather perceptive of you
I hate you partridge then shot
McAllister with a dueling pistol and he
died I am proud of that and there are
other privileges to restaurant criticism
I was allowed into rules just for
pudding after I explained that I had
eaten up morrow and Farringdon and
needed golden syrup pudding to recover I
was at morrow stalking Tony Gallagher
who had just left the editorship of the
Daily Telegraph for a job in a kitchen
Bryan Cranston of Breaking Bad touched
me as I ate in a restaurant on the stage
at the National Theatre during Network I
ate in Prince Charles's gazebo at
Highgrove when he wasn't there
my mother uses my name to get
reservations Corbin and King the best
restaurateurs in London the Delauney
/ Woolsey Fisher's know her game but
they let her get away with it I have
done specialist chip restaurants
specialist lasagna restaurants
specialist cereal restaurants and to
many specialists steak restaurants the
best is beast even if it's told it's
thetic from the Saw franchise the worst
food I ever had was in Trump Tower
followed by pharmacy spelt with an F and
it's plant-based hot chocolate my
greatest regret was my failure to get
into the specialist Cadbury's Creme Egg
restaurant I think about it when I am
insomniac it is rare that I review a
restaurant that I think you will not
like or will at least enjoy for its
absurdity although I made an exception
for the naked pop-up Burnie Rd I visited
because my husband liked the idea the
naked waitress in a faith Glade in a
former pub in South London he got a
naked bored man from Belgium raw meat
and berries it is rare that I'm insulted
although Keith McNally threw me out of
Balthazar in Covent Garden for smoking
available I didn't mind I hated him
after Sarah's like Cafe Rouge but worse
and the worse the restaurant the better
the review it's hard to write well about
perfection and harder try it well about
mediocrity that is how I defend my other
choices we were not eating the review
you are reading it I'm not going to
force you to go on Vikings River splash
at Legoland I'm still glad I went to
Petros tex-mex Cantina and Norwich after
they were banned from UEA for handing
out some barriers I would love to bring
you a review from restaurants that
existed in 1828 but I've done them all
at least twice and some three times
Wilton's rules they're closed for now
incidentally hired on Piccadilly is
doing takeout Ollie dabbu is the best
chef of his generation
so his takeout will be singular if you
do please write to me and tell me how it
was I could have done the Admiral Benbow
pub in Chapel Street in Penzance which
was ancient by 1828 and probably full of
spectator readers moaning about France
but there is a full-size papier-mache
pirate on the roof and considering the
gravity of this issue I didn't feel it
had the right sense of occasion that was
Tanya gold thanks for listening and
remember you can always let us know what
you think about this podcast as well as
who you'd like to hear next at podcast
out spectator code or ek thanks for
listening and join us again for the next
episode
you